welcome back to Las Vegas now tis the
season of giving and Subaru of Las Vegas
time of the year you see the Christmas
trees are up here at Subaru and we're
ready to share the love right Burton we
are already set and go I know right I
know I told you this is my first
Christmas tree of the Season here it's
time so tell us more about Subaru share
the love event and what we're in too
well we look forward to this every year
this is our 15th year of the Subaru
share the love event and it really is a
celebration of all of the Charities uh
you know that are doing such great work
and of course we support there's four
National Charities that Subaru has
selected uh the ASPCA the Make-A-Wish
organization uh Meals on Wheels America
and the national park foundation so
those are National Charities are that
are going to be recipients of this great
event we also have a couple Hometown
Charities that were we're very proud to
present a check to later on when when we
collect all the money and that is
they're going to be the Red Rock search
and rescue which is a great organization
and also the just one project now why
these Charities well I'll tell you Red
Rock search and rescue is our Legacy
charity we when we were able to add a
HomeTown charity I think it was back in
2012 so 10 years ago we selected them
because they really do a great work all
volunteer First Responders
retired military people that really care
about the community in a special way and
we knew that we could make a difference
in helping fund their work not only
looking for people out there in the
mountains in Red Rock and the canyons
and stuff but also here in town you know
people that are lost Alzheimer's
patients children it's a great work and
and then we have a rotating second
charity and this is the second year that
we have actually selected the just one
project they do pop-up give Community
give markets and they have such great
resources that you know that they engage
with the local community to help meet
those needs now I've been here when you
presented checks to both of those
organizations and they were just so
grateful you do this every year you know
what does it mean to make that kind of
impact
it's powerful I mean uh you know it
truly is more blessed to give than to
receive and this year the national
amount that is going to be given will I
think will total 250 million over the
course of the Subaru show the love event
and locally we've been able to donate
over the past uh 15 years about three
hundred thousand dollars so the amounts
that we're going to be able to bless
these Charities with uh is sizable and
so we're really excited about that and
Beyond charity of course Subaru is about
cars too you know what's new in that
department well we finally have cars in
stock for immediate delivery you know
for the last year and a half you had to
order a new Subaru in order to take one
out the door and but now we finally have
some on-ground inventory to choose from
you can still order a car if you want to
but you know it's just a great time
rates are still really good I mean we
have rates as low as 3.9 percent
financing for up to 48 months on
approved credit uh you know for
well-qualified buyers and so it's still
a great time to buy and what better time
than the Subaru share of the love event
getting us in the spirit thank you to
Findlay Subaru of Las Vegas for
sponsoring that segment stop by on Roy
horn way or call
702-495-2100 for more information
Jillian I'll send it to you